let's go next - where do we want to go
let's go to our caller from the
nine-to-five area code who's calling
today from 9:00 to 5:00
either me yeah that's you
hi David I'm a huge fan of this show I
just wanted to ask you about again the
impeachment process right now you know
with the release of the transcript there
seems to be clearly enough evidence for
impeachment but the volume I'm getting
from Republicans is they see this as an
absolute when they know that impeachment
has like horrible approval rating I
think I think it's around 30% I'm not
sure and they think it'll help them in
2020 yeah seems that both sides are
assuming this is a win for them and it
seems that there's going to be one clear
winner and loser I'm um I'm just gonna
ask like based on this do you see this
as hurting the Democrats in 2020 or
helping them it so my commentary this
week has been that it depends on what
actually happens and and it's basically
three different things number one what
information that was previously unknown
to the general public is revealed
through the impeachment inquiry process
that's question number one question
number two just Donald Trump
successfully turn himself into the
victim martyr whatever phrase you want
to use because that would absolutely
embolden Trump and then the other thing
I think is important I don't know where
you're getting the number that only 30%
of Americans are in favor of impeachment
last I looked more than half of the
country was in favor of an impeachment
inquiry I don't see any evidence to
suggest that's changed okay okay I
didn't know that yeah I mean that was my
question thank you that I'm curious so
where did you get that thirty percent of
the country supports impeachment um I
got it from the hill they just put out a
video today about it I think and they
mentioned it's around 30 35 percent I
think okay about 50 percent okay okay
yeah all right thank you okay thank you
for the call I appreciate it